I think I'm gonna throw the whole is it
a sequel to bright I never I'm like
that's this like a John thing that I'll
be like should I repeat that joke on
camera or is that gonna seem tacky
because the people hello reject nation
this is Greg Alva here and it's John
over Oh way over here we got with us
today the awesome reaction channel that
I greatly love and respect and our way
better than us in the Schmo down late to
the party over here all together we
figured why not do some reactions to get
over here just spent the last hour and a
half hanging out didn't know each other
turns out these guys are real douchebags
who you think they are on camera way
worse off do you guys know that right
now anyway we're gonna watch together
the Netflix trailer this film called
dark I have no idea what it's about I'm
sure because the word dark is in the
title pills over here anyway yeah let's
watch it walk over to
[Music]
I know what you did last summer she's
got the slicker
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ever since
[Music]
the future
[Music]
and stranger things a little
when oh yeah okay
all right that's really straightforward
title we have simplicity seems to be the
name of the game this year I don't know
this is an actual foreign film
they're bringing here or if they shot
something that is in a foreign language
and they're just putting it on Netflix
itself it's a series Oh episodes will
air okay to film visually striking
obviously it reminds me a lot of murder
mysteries and always look cooler and
trailers than they are actually yeah
wouldn't you see it like the Snowman or
the girl on the train but then at the
same time though a lot of those movies
have like a foreign director who do who
does an American villain doesn't turn
out so good so then I think of like The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo which had a
which was a great foreign film even
though I like the American version it
does have the American version I so do i
Roberts good Meier Bray there's a lot of
combinations of other Netflix things and
other things we have seen we've kept
referencing it you know thereafter there
are some appeal about that let's look a
little bit like stranger things has some
saw elements to it well it's really cool
about it though is while this trailer
was really capitalizing on mystery I
feel like it really is gonna be a huge
psychological thriller of trying to
figure out who you know did you guys see
the HBO miniseries they little lies I
don't know okay well that whole season
is dedicated to what was the crime and
who is committing the crime and the
whole time we're trying to figure it out
whodunit yeah whodunit yeah and I like a
whole series dedicated to that as
opposed to like a two-hour movie an
entire series sounds really awesome I
can see a lot of appealing elements to
it and the fact that's in a foreign
language just makes me feel smarter as
an
a lot of reading taking place yeah they
have to hit your eyeballs focus on those
captions keep it yeah in fact I didn't
realize it until you were reading it for
us and I was like oh there's captions I
don't understand
I was so captivated by the visuals of
what was actually happening in this
trailer like you said though definitely
a lot of homage to other things that we
have seen although they're fantastic
things yeah one of the big things though
that I think was really cool element
added into stranger things at least this
season is adding the abilities of some
of the people in the show for instance
we've got eleven and if you haven't seen
stranger things to others that's
something that I'm interested to see
because clearly this person did ginger
with the thing around the head and the
slicker went through some torment and
possibly gave them abilities of
time-travel we saw the lights flickering
perhaps yeah yeah and the fact that it
was like it's not whoo it's not how it's
not why it's when yeah exactly like is
there a sci-fi element to because it
seems like they're not ending at that
but I like a subtle sci-fi not like an
overblown one for me though for this it
really reminded me of the show wayward
Pines okay very very much so great like
this as soon as we got the characters
and then them being in the town and it
the town just being creepy and it's
weird and you don't know what's going on
I'm like oh it kind of reminds me
wayward Pines they maybe got inspiration
between the two tougher brothers did
wayward Pines yes and one as well that
did stranger things so yeah so Netflix
is the perfect platform for the cutter
yeah but also broadchurch yeah I thought
yeah anchors to this sort of like
contained crime story over one season
and you really get to know all the
facets and by the end you finally get
the catharsis of the reveal and stuff
like that this kind of reminded me of a
whole bunch of things that you all have
named sorry again there any at
broadchurch was sort of the last piece
of that for me I'm intrigued by this and
I liked that Netflix is in a position
where they can bring us a foreign series
I'm interested to check this out partly
because of that because it seems like it
has an actual foreign sensibility and
it's not trying to cram itself into the
American idea
I mean Netflix kind of worried had like
another one - I know we're breaking like
all of these references from other shows
but Netflix in particular had one called
Hemlock Grove and it also gave me that
feel as well so I'm really excited that
Netflix is branching out and granted
Netflix is in other countries and they
have their own yeah version distribution
of different movies - that certain
region of countries but to bring it to
an audience that Pali normally won't
watch types of movies like that is a
really good way to kind of expand the
movie you're like for people who love
movies and don't have the ability to get
those movies true are able to see it on
Netflix
well that books also has narcos though
which is all Spanish they are the only
like cable channel that is experimenting
with foreign language yeah yeah well the
most part yeah across the board I mean
it seems like they have a pretty
interesting selection of originals the
stuff they put their name on it seems
like they have interesting judgment and
they're usually not doing the same kind
of thing over and over again
and as a trailer just just as a thing
designed to make me want to watch this
show I'm kind of torn on it because I am
reminded of a whole lot of things but I
feel like it's vague enough and
intriguing enough and there's enough
sort of like what is that whole thing
with the chair I'm like what is there
and so like it doesn't treat me to want
to check out the show at least yeah and
yeah it just comes down to is it gonna
be as compelling as this trailer was
gonna be for all we know they're gonna
just take the visual cues that would
actually cause us to perk up and say huh
and it's nothing like yeah let's piece
it together they don't get that I think
it would be funny if they did the
reverse with this one where since the
title alludes to the idea that this is
gonna be heavy just make it like super
light-hearted yeah alright guys well
dark another show that I have to add to
my list of the 4,000 shows that are now
out already that I am behind on okay i
thing about Netflix though is that they
designed their show specifically to
binge watch and it's very well it's very
yeah yeah that's the that's a great
benefit of it is you feel you're gonna
knock it all out all right guys let's
dark what do you think of dark yay
that's called engagement
right throwing a TIA out it to you down
put it in the comments send it back
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell you can
follow us on social media become a
patron eject today because everything
you guys help out up with our patreon
goes back to this channel directly plus
there's some awesome rewards for you
guys most importantly if you don't want
to do any of that what I would love you
guys to do is please check out late to
the party's channel there's a lot of
reaction channels out there on YouTube
and they are one of the few that I
really do enjoy watching yeah the other
ones that I know of that I do enjoy
watching with these guys specifically I
really do love their commentary I love
their input there's a reason they're
also on the Schmoe down so please go
check out their channel subscriber them
link in the description box
good day people